the Federal Trade Commission is suing
Amazon for allegedly deceptive tactics
with customers the agency says the
retailer duped people into signing up
for his prime service and then made it
difficult to cancel our consumer
investigative correspondent Anna Werner
has signed up to look into this
crime members get holiday deals before
anyone else crime is a major Money Maker
for Amazon it has more than 200 million
subscribers worldwide who pay fees
generating 25 billion dollars in annual
revenue but now the Federal Trade
Commission is targeting the company for
allegedly using what it calls
manipulative coercive or deceptive
practices known as dark patterns to gain
subscribers and to keep them in a
heavily redacted filing the FTC alleges
Amazon tricked and trapped non-prime
customers into unknowingly signing up
for the service during the checkout
process by quote presenting them with a
prominent button to enroll in Prime and
a comparatively inconspicuous link to
decline it also claims Amazon made it
very difficult to navigate canceling a
Prime subscription with a four-page
six-click and 15 option process the FTC
says Amazon called Iliad after the
nearly sixteen thousand line ancient
poem it's Prime Day is on almost here
the filing also alleges Amazon
Executives knew about the complex and
confusing process and neglected to
change it until April of this year
former FTC chair William kovacic it's
certainly the ftc's perception that
Amazon is hardly alone in this which
again is why I think they're singling
out the company uh as an Exemplar here
as a focal point for a major lawsuit
that is is seeking to change Behavior
across the industry in a statement
Amazon called the ftc's claims false on
the facts and the law saying by Design
we make it clear and simple for
customers to both sign up for or cancel
their Prime Membership before you get
started on your Prime Day festivities
verify your Prime membership for CBS
mornings I'm Anna Werner Amazon shopping